hey I was going bros my name is Peter
Pan welcome back to yandere simulator it
got updated and now you know what that
means more death and more suffering
there are some very very interesting
features in this new update
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway let's go check it man [ __ ] this
that girl have spaghetti his hair hey yo
spaghetti lady oh she lost her bra
[Music]
hey hey this is so embarrassing
okay you look for it Thanks so there's
this shut out here and inside the shed
there it says circular sir Oh how'd you
know I need a circle Oh sir
so the circular saw you can do some
circular interesting things with oh god
there's so many [ __ ] are they doing up
here okay so we can attack this lady oh
my god jesus [ __ ] christ huh
I didn't think I just saw her [ __ ]
face in half Jesus Christ
yanari alright let's just remember her
oh oh how nice
alright let's grab her legs hey I got a
leg what can I do with the leg oh hey
it's just a leg it said sets its leg day
I just had a leg day all right what
about the head oh my god I love her face
oh my god what the [ __ ] hey girl you
want a kiss
you want a kiss you want a kiss her
pretty kisses look at it look at it look
at that look at it oh my god oh my god
that's [ __ ] awesome they're too
scared to run cuz I think they're
[ __ ] hey my titties now ha ha that's
[ __ ] awesome oh it stands up oh my
god alright sorry it was gonna go yeah I
don't like your hair alright so now we
can drag her and I think there's a
feature of picking up as well oh now
that's the spaghetti girl oh right Jesus
Christ
oh okay hey there we go there we go they
don't worry about it I'll come back for
you later [ __ ] think we should give
this as a gift to senpai as a token of
our appreciation bye you killed them
stay back wait wait for me but I just
wanted to give you a gift
okay so let's kill this guy awesome
right so now we dump him we'll pick him
up but I know there's a way to pick them
up as well activate oh my god okay so
now we have the ability to pick this
[ __ ] up there you go oh god you're
heavy oh god you're heavy what have you
panties so now we're also able if the
railing is lower we should be able to
land a little a lot of surprise so for
example we can dump her here
bombs away I don't know why that's funny
I feel horrible now let's pick her up
and bring her through the garage don't
mind me there we go let's put her down
here hahaha let's cut that [ __ ] open
this game is horrible and I love it a
lot my reputation is still high oh my
god it's so [ __ ] up it looks like I
have a little skirt a little Scottish
kilt a joke shop decoy I just want to be
able to dump like the head on someone's
head oh it's sitting there oh that's
good
oh that's really good [ __ ] so now we
can easily dispose of all these bodies
just at once goodbye goodbye now have a
good oh my god that's awesome oh my god
you know what I got I got crazy ideas
from this alright let's cut these huh
[ __ ] up
whoa Jesus if blue
[Music]
Jesus Christ is just getting really
disturbing hey senpei I brought you the
girl you love
now will you love me look simple sit by
where did it go
sit by where are you stand by I'll put
you out sorry wrong room sit by that
back [ __ ] crazy step back [ __ ]
crazy now ah stop it
step I only wanted to lap set by I know
how to doubt you now oh this is good now
[Music]
that's awesome I'm freakin sands baby
that looks very awkward but does it do
it oh my god take this oh [ __ ] is that
my right at the deck Oh least yet
let's talk
[Music]
I love our hits everybody right away
that's [ __ ] to get a pump all right
Bryce thank you so much for watching
another
I love this game and I love all the
updates really bring them to you we were
like enjoy it really helps out a lot
always say us bam bam all right
somebody's he gonna do look at his
[ __ ] face